more airstrikes on Ukraine's Capital
have killed at least two people
Ukrainian officials say three missiles
hit a power facility in Kiev Russia is
striking critical infrastructure across
the country President Vladimir zielinski
says the situation is critical and is
warned of possible electricity and water
outages Nationwide let's go to Mahmoud
Jam who's standing by for us in the cave
and Muhammad tell us more about these
latest strikes
like it was a fresh wave of air strikes
throughout this morning in various
cities across the country including here
in Kiev you mentioned that strike that
hit critical infrastructure facilities
in Kiev that happened in the desnsky
district which is east of the capital
it's on the Left Bank of the danipro
river now the mayor of Ki Vitale
Klitschko says that three people were
killed as a result of those missile
strikes on those critical infrastructure
sites in Kiev and he says that those who
were killed were employees of one of the
facilities that was hit he's also gone
on to say that they are doing all they
can to repair those facilities to make
sure that power continues as much as
possible beyond what happened in Kiev
you also have zerto Mir which is a city
that's neighboring Kiev where missile
strikes occurred and water and
electricity has been out in many areas
there also the city of danipro missiles
hit there and also in Harkey the there
were many missile strikes that took
place there in the overnight hours Nick
President zielinski says he's concerned
about this targeting of infrastructure
30 percent of power stations for example
destroyed
that's right that is a great concern
here right now you have that statement
from President Vladimir zielinski in
which he says that 30 percent of
Ukrainian power plants have been damaged
since October 10th by Russian shelling
you've had other officials many of them
joining this chorus of the over the last
few days from many of the regions and
cities across the country warning people
that as a result of these strikes across
the country uh that the country should
prepare for the possibility of power
outages that they should prepare for the
possibility of power blackouts in the
days to come now where we are here in
Kiev everything is online but we were in
that area that I was telling you about
in my previous answer desninsky just a
few hours ago and we were talking to
Residents who were without power who
could not access water since those
strikes that have happened this morning
and they're very concerned about what's
to come next about the the prospect
especially when temperatures are
dropping and winter is fast approaching
of going without power not being able to
heat their homes now the ministry of
energy it just come out with a statement
in the last 20 minutes or so 20 minutes
or so saying that over 1100 areas
throughout the country are without power
and the national Energy company has also
warned of the possible application of
emergency power shutdown schedules and
they say that people should do all they
can to conserve on energy and should try
to lessen their energy consumption
habits in the days to come Nick
all right that's a picture in Ukraine at
Mo thanks very much for that Muhammad
Johnson reporting there